moi c'est théo au collège je suis pas
très populaire alors toi l'été on a peur
de l'autre lui c'est bonnave mon
meilleur ami elle c'est laura la rebelle
de la classe c koi en bas c'est les
enfers théo c'est pas un endroit pour
les enfants un jour dans un mystérieux
grimoire j'ai découvert la recette d'une
bague d'invisibilité chez nos rares
kandia je fais les centaines de kilos
belle pour ce livre vous allez vous de
retrouver imagine que ça marche qu'on
premier ingrédient mercure liquide top
young de pigeonneaux pas pour moi c'est
mieux et que c'est comme ça qu'on a
rencontré arcand dias et son assistant
pas qu bézian terme est ok réunion entre
m
comment vous avez fait il fait des trucs
dans ma vie quoi vas-y jongle chirurgie
esthétique et comment il finit le moins
visible
c'est la 14e thématiques et la bague
quoi je suis bloqué ce qui pourrait
apparaître
à bâle ça et comment je reste bien
visible ah ça c'est pas possible il nous
reste deux jours 6 heures et 17 minutes
vous occupez de retrouver la bague - de
la potion on va bien sûr qui est en
train de disparaître complètement
je te rappelle que je n'ai jamais raté
ce genre d'émission c'est beaucoup
aucune